diesen Berg von Cookies die mindestens
genauso gut sind wie Subway Cookies
kannst du dir 0 kom n zu Hause machen oh
sch fallen einfach ihr werdet euch
wahrscheinlich schon denken wir brauchen
Zucker und zwar weißen Zucker und
braunen Zucker die Mengenangaben findet
ihr wie immer in der Beschreibung es
folgt geschmolzene Butter als nächstes
Vanilleextrakt und ein Ei dann setzen
wir ein Sieb auf unsere Schüssel geben
hinein Mehl Salz und Natron und das
sieben wir jetzt einfach durch nach ein
bisschen rühren sieht das ganze dann
auch schon so aus und jetzt haut ihr
einfach rein worauf ihr Lust habt ihr
könnt maadamia reinmachen ihr könnt
weiße Schokolade dunkle Schokolade oder
beides ebenfalls unter heben so kommt
das jetzt für 30 Minuten in den
Kühlschrank 30 Minuten später ist unser
Cookie Teig kühl und ich hole mir mit so
einem Löffel eine ordentliche Portion
raus forme den einmal zu einer Kugel und
platziere ihn auf meinem Backblech und
dann ab in den Backofen 160° 8 bis 10
Minuten und jetzt heißt es aufmerksam
sein denn wir wollen die perfekte
Konsistenz treffen dieses typisch softe
klebrige ungefähr 10 Minuten bei 180°
später sehen unsere Cookies so aus lass
die Cookies jetzt so einfach ein
bisschen abkühlen wenn ihr denkt die
sind noch zu weich dann liegt ihr falsch
weil genauso werden sie wenn sie kühl
sind perfekt weich